Celebrity detectives, suicidal
superheroes, and elementary school
astronauts? Grab some popcorn and check
out the new gems Netflix has to offer.
A hair-raising horror story, the
supernatural series "Archive 81"
takes viewers on quite the thrill ride.
The show follows archivist Dan Turner,
played by Mamoudou Athie, who is tasked with
restoring tapes burned in an apartment fire.
Working in an extremely desolate location,
Dan must also piece together any information
he can about what actually happened during the
blaze. The more Dan uncovers from the footage,
which was filmed by Dina Shihabi's character,
Melody, the weirder circumstances get.
Based on the 2016 podcast of the same name,
"Archive 81" has received high praise from
critics and fans. Despite this success,
the series was canceled after one season.
Spy thriller "In From the Cold" follows Jenny —
a.k.a. Anya — a Russian spy once known as "the
Whisper" until she went into hiding in the United
States. Played by Margarita Levieva, Jenny is
a divorced mother, who wants to prioritize her
family but gets pulled back into her old way of
life when she's discovered and forced to embark
on a series of dangerous missions in Madrid.
This spy thriller proves that a work-life balance
isn't always easy to achieve, especially when the
work portion revolves around guns, violence, and
being an all-out assassin. Though this might not
be the most relatable sentiment, "In From the
Cold" is an enticing spy series that adds its
own spin on the well-worn genre and hooks its
audience with a series of thrilling twists.
If you're a an of oddball murder mysteries,
then "Murderville" is a must-watch.
This improvisation-driven comedy follows
mustache-twirling detective Terry Seattle,
played by "Arrested Development"
star Will Arnett, as he solves cases
alongside celebrity guest stars and keeps
the audience laughing from start to finish.
"Senior detective Terry Seattle.
And no, I've never been."
"Hm, that was gonna be my first question."
"'Course it was."
Without giving too much away, a few of Terry's
all-star assistants include Annie Murphy,
Ken Jeong, and Kumail Nanjiani. Since much of
the series is made up of unscripted elements,
these unsuspecting celebrities are taken on as
much of a comedy-filled ride as the audience.
A crime mystery based in Indonesia,
"Photocopier" follows a young woman
named Sur, played by Shenina Cinnamon,
who encounters a worst-case scenario when
a compromising selfie begins to make
its rounds after a night of drinking.
The fallout is swift and severe as she loses
her scholarship and faces ridicule from her
parents. Perhaps worst of all, she doesn't
remember the events of the night before.
Sur must retrace her steps to
figure out what really happened,
a mystery that's flooded with blurred lines
and deception. "Photocopier" has seen screaming
success in reviews from critics and fans
alike, and it will have viewers on the edge
of their seats while they try to piece together a
black-out-induced night with the main characters.
If the title "The Woman in the House Across
the Street from the Girl in the Window" sounds
familiar, it's because the series is a parody of
the Netflix thriller "The Woman in the Window"
as well as other mystery psychological material
in the same vein. The film follows Anna,
played by Kristen Bell, a grieving alcoholic
who believes she's witnessed a murder.
Unfortunately, no one, including the
authorities, takes her seriously,
as she often has hallucinations. From a boring
existence staring out a window to solving a
possible murder case on her own, Anna's life is
turned upside down in this dark comedy thriller.
"I swear I know what I saw,
okay? I saw her dying."
Though spoofs tend to be flooded with clichés,
this latest parody installment is worth a
watch for comedy and thriller fans alike.
"Windfall" follows a man,
known simply as the robber,
who breaks into a vacation home
owned by a well-to-do couple.
When the husband and wife arrive at their
getaway home, instead of fleeing the scene,
the robber decides to take the two hostage inside
their own house. The heist slowly falls apart
as it's revealed that this particular married
couple aren't exactly living in marital bliss.
Despite the film's simplistic nature,
"Windfall" is gifted with an explosive
cast, featuring Jason Segel as the
robber, Lily Collins as the wife,
and Jesse Plemons as the CEO. As John
Nugent of Empire Magazine observes,
"Short, sharp and mostly satisfying,
this is a thriller that sticks to the
stripped-back fundamentals of the genre."
Imagine being 10 years old and getting recruited
by NASA to go on a secret mission to the moon.
That's exactly what happens to
protagonist Stan in "Apollo 10½:
A Space Age Childhood," which intertwines
a nostalgic depiction of growing up in
1960s Houston with a fanciful story
about becoming a child astronaut.
Boasting a gifted cast featuring Glen
Powell, Jack Black, and Zachary Levi,
it's no wonder why this film received high
praise from audience members and critics alike.
Though "Apollo 10½: A Space Age Childhood"
might be most appealing to baby boomers,
its riveting animation and creative
storytelling make it enjoyable
viewing for all ages.
With a resume including unauthorized spoofs
of "The Punisher" and "Power Rangers,"
as well as well-received adaptations of "Dredd"
and "Castlevania," Adi Shankar has breathed new,
revisionist life into familiar genre fare. His
latest work, the partially animated series,
"The Guardians of Justice (Will Save You),"
specifically celebrates superhero series like
DC Comics and Warner Brothers' deadly
serious "Justice League'' franchise.
The story begins in the late 1980s,
following a long period of global
peace when extraterrestrial superhero
Marvelous Man, played by Will Yun Lee,
saved the planet from the clutches of Robo-Hitler
and a deadly Third World War. When Marvelous
Man dies of an apparent suicide, his former
teammate Knight Hawk begins investigating his
late captain's passing. Should Knight Hawk
and the other Guardians fail to rise to the
challenge and fill the void left by Marvelous Man,
Earth could face yet another global catastrophe.
Following his long run as a creator, producer,
and showrunner on HBO's epic fantasy series,
"Game of Thrones" D.B. Weiss went the completely
opposite direction with his next project:
a charming, musically oriented high school comedy
called "Metal Lords." In this Netflix film,
Hunter, played by Adrian Greensmith, is a
devotee of the darkest and hardest heavy metal,
and he desperately wants to start
a band. In pursuit of his dream,
he recruits his best friend and marching
band percussionist, Kevin, to play drums.
"Meet me after school. We've got work to do."
"Metal Lords" tracks the duo's
progress as they find their sound,
transform an overstressed orchestra
cellist into a metal bassist,
and prepare for an impending Battle of the
Bands. Wholesome and nostalgic, "Metal Lords"
feels simultaneously familiar and unique in its
portrayal of high school friendships and romances.